There are certain analytics that game
developers should always be thinking
about, and it always starts at
the high level of lifetime value.
Once you have a good idea of
how you want to measure or
calculate your lifetime value, then
you can determine what other analytics
in particular that you
want to be looking at.
For instance, usually everybody
starts with retention, so
that's the number of people
who are coming back or
the percentage of people who
are coming back on specific days.
Day 1, day 14, day 28.
On the monetization side,
it really depends on the type of
monetization method that you're using.
So, if you're using
primarily in-app purchases,
then you want to look at
the average revenue per purchase.
The average purchase size.
If you're looking at things
such as monetizing through ads,
then you want to look at ad
specific monetization metrics.
So things like the effective
cost per thousand.
The ECPM, the fill rate.
As well as, frequencies that you're
showing ads, things like that.
All of this is generally distilled into
the ARPU, the average revenue per user.
Or the RPPU which is the average
revenue per paying user.
And along the way you can make up
whatever acronyms make the most sense
for your game.